we have underestimated all the
ramifications of terenia the situation
is not in your control is it how could
you let it get to this point you're the
majority it might be wrong this is a
party which is absorbing fascist roots
what do you do you just keep voting
until you get the the election result
that you want this week conflict zone is
at the Munich Security Conference in
Germany a country that has just been
plunged into a leadership crisis and
confronted with the specter of its Nazi
past
miracles hand-picked successor anagram
Karen Bauer has stepped down after her
CD new members defied orders and voted
with the far-right in the German state
of Turanga my guest is a CDU
parliamentarian who serves on the
Foreign Affairs Committee Ken his party
find its soul and its backbone as Europe
and the world looks to Germany to lead
[Music]
Roderick is a vet - welcome how could an
election in Terraria one of the smallest
German states bring down the
hand-selected successor - angle America
autograph from Karen Bauer are you that
weak as a party well I don't think so
but we have underestimated all the
ramifications of terenia also that we
have to recognize that the Christian
Democratic Union has lost the elections
in this country some months ago and we
have not taken serious consequences so
this was the first mistake inside the
party of Tauranga the second mistake was
that we have underestimated the role of
the Parliament entering here and third
we have underestimated ran the law and
the AFD and therefore I think we should
be very decent and very careful for the
next weeks let's talk a little bit more
about the AFD because Angela Merkel
German Chancellor has calls for a new
election the AFD is feasting on this
chaos they say the following they say
that a new election is not democratic
and the CDU is ignoring a quarter of the
electorate how could you
the governing CDU get played so badly by
the far-right AFD well in tauranga there
was a very left coalition and not the
CDU the studio was at the opposition so
we are not a governing party in
Thuringia we have been there a governing
party for 25 years however entering here
the AFD has shown that they vote
recklessly they vote only for trying to
split the cohesion of the central
democratic parties and we have to accept
that inside Germany we have a strong
protest notion inside the population and
we have to take this serious the IFD is
exploiting the sense for a position or
this sense for turmoil inside the
population a lot of people who feel left
behind try to make use of the AFD as a
protest party and the politicians of the
AFD
exploited that so what do you do now
because I mean you have for example the
leader of the AFT in the Bundestag Alice
vital saying the following a state
premier was democratically elected from
democratically elected representatives
then the chancellor comes in and says
this election has to be undone and
voided so what do you do you just keep
voting until you get the the election
result that you want we have to stay to
the to the reality the reality was that
the AFD has had a candidate who gained
zero votes in the parliament so it was a
fake candidate and no other party was
aware about this chess game of the AFD
so they are trying to exploit a
democratic procedure by not voting for
their own candidate but voting for a
probably mid-center are you getting
you're getting played the issue the
issue is we have to be careful much more
careful than in the past and the AFD is
not behaving like a normal competitor
they are behaving like a spoiler is this
a legacy of Angela Merkel though because
I mean you've seen him/her now 15 years
as German Chancellor she's pushed the
party so far to the left she's created
this space for the far-right AFD they're
now the largest opposition party in the
Bundestag they are playing kingmaker
inter alia as you yourself have
highlighted well they are not the
largest opposition party they are the
largest opposition party but they have
only 90 seats so we should not
overestimate it second as regards the
role of our party we are in the center
and Angela Merkel has detected that
normally in Germany you have a left
majority and it is her merit that she
has achieved since 2005 a center
oriented policy in Germany with a
participation of the CDU without this
idea we would have been in the
opposition since 10 or 15 years again so
she brought the CEO to the center and on
the other side you are right they erased
was raised a right-wing party but this
was also combined with some migration
issues and with the rural areas who
sometimes feel left behind
four percent of Germans believe that the
scandal in Tirana had damaged their
trust in democracy and it has it has
shaken this country to its core the
reaction has been fast and furious
weren't you aware of the damage that
this could cause I mean you had 17
members of the Tauranga government CDU
members who were elected who called for
you for help they called for you months
ago they called for you in October well
I don't want to blame the Tyrrhenian sea
do but they have made also some serious
mistakes first of all the leader of the
party has lost the election but he stood
in office so this was wrong he didn't
open his seat for others second in
preparation of the election of a mellow
he was or this election from the left he
was not aware about the chess game so
they are have been black ayat at that
time so my guess is that first of all
the Tyrrhenian CEO has to take over the
responsibility second the CEO in Germany
has to be aware that the population in
eastern Germany is not willing to accept
influence from the from the outside but
if we influence from the outside I am a
defender of Angela Merkel then we should
explain why we cannot accept that a
party which is defending 12 years of
dictatorship as some excrements of a
bird that such a party is trying to be
part of a process or for to through a
country so let us talk about this
strategy with how you deal with that
party right now and the merits of that
strategy your party in Hamburg in 2018
you came up with the following directive
that the CDU rejects coalition's and
similar forms of cooperation both with
the Left Party and the right AFD how do
you plan on maintaining that when we
look at touring it for example 54
percent of the voters in this German
state voted for fringe parties that you
won't cooperate with yeah but that's
also a majority might be wrong but it's
democracy
democracy it's democracy you are right
but the AFD those voters their rules
don't matter no but we have to explain
what the AFD has in in behind what it's
thinking from behind what's where is
leading who is leading from behind and
that this is a party which is absorbing
fascist roots and is absorbing fascists
fascists powers inside Germany so we
have a neglect able NPD we have an it
neglect able dvu former right-wing
parties who all went over to the AFD
okay well I'm gonna talk with you about
how you maintain your majority
nationally because that's also falling
in the polls
currently the CDU pulling at just 27
percent nationally you have very
conservative members in your party for
example the veteran young you have
called for its dissolution yeah wouldn't
you just be hand delivering more votes
to the AFD I don't think so
I think if the CDU where would they go
you're hoping that they form their
another new party another party on the
far-right the voters of the AFD have
several sources a quarter of them are
from the CDU nearly if the half are
those who have have abstained towards
for years for decades nearly and the
other third is from Social Democrats and
other parties from the Left Party even
in the east in the eastern countries so
it's not a sister or a children of the
CDU it's a children of leaving the
countryside at home aside behind it's a
sign for neglecting the needs of the
people in the in the five new lenda in
germany of germany and third we should
be very well aware that the AFD is a
party with fascist roots but we should
not blame the voters we should name and
shame the defenders of this wrong policy
like hookah and we cannot cooperate with
heads of a party who are very very
right-wing
but for the CDU in the our Republic we
should stay to the center if we turn to
the right if we shift to the right we
will lose in the center and we will lose
more than we might gain at the right
a very famous quote I'd like to bring in
now from franz josef strauß legendary
prime minister of bavaria and former
candidate for chancellor no legitimate
political party can be to the right of
the CSU your sister party the CDU you
work together you can adhere to that
mantra it can't work because now the
right scene is also occupied by fascists
and we cannot be more right-wing and
then the fascists are we have to really
separate us from such thinking second
strauss never became chancellor and we
should not repeat the mistakes if we if
we offer right-wing candidates for
chancellorship to conservative people we
won't win we will create opposition
leaders but we will not create
Chancellor's we will create chances we
are in the center here's what the
Germans think is going to happen in your
country 48% believe that the AFD will be
part of a regional or federal government
in the next 10 years
26% think it is okay that the AFD
participates in a regional government
19% support the AFD as part of a federal
government the situation is not in your
control is it how could you get it as
far as your point you are very
experienced as far as you know we have
since the beginning of a Federal
Republic of Germany we have a right wing
up to a right a right wing oriented
population up to 25% this has not
changed since the 50s and now the people
are themselves even more frankly than in
the past so we have to be very aware
that we have about twenty to thirty
percent who are able and willing to vote
very right-wing parties and about 10 to
15% who are really fascist so we have to
invest more in education and in
explanation and second for me it's of
utmost importance not to accept that
such parties create governments we
should be here very clear
Unger cream can bar is now stepping down
as head of the party she will not run
for Chancellor
she was the successor who was picked by
both your party and by Angela Merkel
herself was she a bad pick
I don't think so but she has made some
bad choices she hasn't lost 21% of
people in the country or who are happy
with her performance that's just six
percent better than the AFD had
Alexander garland it's the it's also a
question of how you you raised the
question and how you formulate the
questions and on the other side she has
achieved something which nearly is
forgotten
she has reconciliate 'add CSU and CDU
this is her really biggest merit as
regards as the party chief now she's out
there's a power vacuum here at the
Munich Security Conference we know that
the world is increasingly turning to
Germany calling on Germany for a
leadership I just still like to take a
moment to talk a little bit more about
Germany's track record on an
international stage and we can begin
with Syria on October 21st 2019 defense
minister Round Rock Rome carambar made a
proposal for a security zone in Syria
similar to a proposal that you had made
years earlier she brought the proposal
to NATO effused a few days later how did
that go well the proposal itself is very
valuable very estimated but at that time
very impractical they're very practical
because it shows to the United States
that the Europeans are willing for
burden-sharing
and this was the the core idea European
burn sharing combined with a United
Nations Security mandate however the
proposal came either too late or too
early so you need to defer tail it with
other initiatives and you have to also
coordinate this with other parties and
to coordinate it inside the government
your own foreign minister said we are
being told from all sides this plan is
not realistic the people in Syria don't
have time for theoretical debates so I
mean what's better for you is it better
to have a good plan that's not enacted
or a plan that actually helps people
well the plan which helps people is
still missing and it's still too the
fact that the European Union has not a
quote qualitative majority vote but
need to act unanimously so this is the
the real area of European ability to act
and unfortunately this is not over has
not yet been overcome but analytically
calendar has also made here in Munich
has made a lot of proposals how to
overcome this and Borel the successor of
missus mogherini made it very clear
these days that the European ability to
act is only lip service and we need to
overcome that the situation is dire the
situation is currently at our doorstep
we have your own Interior Minister
saying that we are going to have a
second 2015 if we do not help countries
at the EU borders with how to deal with
migration three million civilians in it
live amid a government offensive six
hundred thousand have already been
displaced since December what are you
doing well this is the idea of an eclair
come combo about the safety zone we need
a UN mandate and then to prepare an
action are two different things but this
is a necessary a really a necessary step
because if you don't get United Nations
into action you will lose the
international credibility of the United
Nations itself and it's a question of
diplomatic endeavor to bring in not a
Chinese or an irrational against it so
you need to convince them and you need
to offer them something that's a
question of negotiation and we should do
this we should try to achieve a secure
and safe haven either in North Syria or
in western part of Iraq to have a safe
haven for refugees under United Nations
control combined with with other
partners because the Turks and the
Russians just completely bypassed you
and they did it on their own yeah why
did they do that because the European
Union was not able to act
there was no willingness and therefore
we had need these German proposals
because it was Germany which hampered
for example a European action in the
Straits of Hormuz a little bit more
about your partnership some you
mentioned the United Nations the
European Union I want to talk about NATO
Germany made the following commitment in
2014
NATO leaders they all recommitted to
increasing defense spending and spending
2% of GDP by 2024 do you know what the
number is yeah current government report
when the released its 11.5 percent by
2024 currently we are with your partners
well our caucus Christian Democratic and
Christian social Union we demanded to
achieve this by the end of this period
so that means in 2021 but our coalition
partner the SPD didn't want that at all
so we need to find compromises and what
the compromise was to achieve that goal
by 2025 however the pure numbers won't
help this would be about 60 billion
euros some five years ago we had nearly
32 billion euros so that would mean to
nearly double it by 2025 and 2 percent
would mean 80 billion euros who takes
you seriously though if you can't even
abide to your commitments on the
international scale because you have
those internal dynamics regarding your
current coalition and your parties
within the country who takes you
seriously we need to calm down because
we are very honest and our defence
minister as was the Chancellor made the
commitment 1.5 percent by 2025 due to
our coalition commitments and to to
continue and to achieve the 2 percent
goal by 2030 one I know as a simple
member of parliament that this is too
long too late but we have also an armed
forces which was not able to absorb any
further money because all the changes
with which I needed all the reforms are
not yet do the reforms are overdue but
they are not yet in action not yet
practicable so that needs that means we
need further time second it's not only
the figure what we need is more
interoperability and more
standardization and then we could also
save money we have 32 armies in the
European Union and we need to reform
that all these 32 armies have at least
the same procedures and
nearly the same equipment let's talk a
little bit more about about the
readiness of your army to respond to
that common defense clause within NATO
we have from the Bundeswehr omni boots
Minh he says the following there's not
enough equipment not enough personnel
too much bureaucracy you have a fleet of
submarines stuck in port because they
didn't have required propellers you have
tank battalions operating at one fourth
of capacity Luftwaffe pilots not being
able to log into flight hours to compete
can can your allies rely on you to be
ready
well what as regards our commitment to
the Balkans or to Afghanistan or to
Africa or the Baltic Air Policing we
fully achieve all benchmarks but what is
up to reforms still the domestic
situation of our armed forces and this
is really horrible and the Ombudsman you
just mentioned it is repeating this
since five years however look where we
come from where our pacifist country we
have had twenty years from my dear is
this country however with with
aspirations to lead on the international
scale when it comes to involvement in
conflicts where military deterrence and
military action might be needed don't
you need a functional Bundeswehr or do
you just plan to sit on the sidelines
until you eventually as a forester I
know a functioning army since then early
1990s and I know a dysfunctional Army's
the last 25 years and we have achieved a
lot now and the the Armed Forces the
Bundeswehr is on a very good way however
it will take another 10 years because it
was nearly dismantled as regards our
combat forces if what was nearly
dismantled as regards our stocks of
ammunition since 2011 the war against
Libya we have not refilled our
ammunition stocks so we come from our
narrative voice we are encircled by
partners and friends so we could focus
on security on Social Security
we offer 8% of the world of the of the
world spending for Social Welfare its
Germany 8% we have 1% of the population
of the world and we offered 8% of the
world's social spending but we do not
match our code men made men since 2014
but we know too
that because since 1990 we have
fulfilled that so we need to turn back
to our former commitments and endeavors
we had we know how it works but we
didn't do that let's talk about another
security concern Nord Stream 2 it's been
heavily criticized by the United States
and the European Union for facilitating
German dependence on on Russian gas you
said the following about it I'm
skeptical of Nord Stream 2 but it is
still Russian gas that Europe needs
Germany has more than two-thirds of its
gas supplies from Russia which cannot be
discussed away so you want to have your
cake and eat it first of all the
Americans should calm down because they
import billions of barrels no but
millions of barrels of Russian oil and
they should come down and look the
Europeans also calm down there's an open
letter from 60 member of Parliament's
from five political groups who wrote the
following to Angela Merkel choose the
European way and not the Germany way
first year government is allowing a
major rift between EU member countries -
remarks on that I was not defending
Nostrum - since 2012 until last year but
you - the dramatic development in the
German energy change we need really
North stream - because otherwise we
could not achieve our own energy so
you're prepared to sell your energy
security to Russia our energy security
is really the mistake was done 15 years
ago when Chancellor schröder
went into Russian services and therefore
we have made these mistakes and I am
very bluntly in this way we politicians
and I I would would be very careful
because we all are guilty in that we
have named this as a economic project it
isn't an economic project it was the
advantage of shrewder to name this as an
economic project it's a purely political
one and now we cannot withdraw from it
but we have also taken it because we can
try to influence Russia but I am NOT I'm
not a defender of North stream - for
economic reasons I think we really
needed to achieve
our energy change and we need an
influencer to Russia but it is not a
good choice let's talk about digital
independence there are some security
concerns there as well in US Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo I'm saying here at
the Munich Security Conference that
Huawei is the Trojan horse of Chinese
intelligence and yet you're not banning
it from the bidding process of building
your 5g network here in Germany why well
we have some role models like the United
Kingdom for example or France they all
seem to be in a certain fear of losing
cooperation chances with China but I
don't want to be ironic
look some of the I only know the German
word antenna the antenna the sensors of
5 G are made from rheinmetall and they
are created in China 100% of the Huawei
antenna are made from a job it's very
interesting technicals but how you know
how about the accusations here now we in
the Parliament have achieved a change in
the governmental papers on that and we
have achieved that our government has to
reconsider some of its position and this
was achieved last week so also a strong
position on Telecom that the leading
telecom provider in your country they
are already in talks with Huawei 2x5 70%
of radio transmission gear for 5g I mean
those talks are already happening and
you're you're talking in the parliament
when Deutsche Telekom is negotiating
deals with Huawei already well one of
the main law of the bigger sponsors of
the Munich Security Conference is Huawei
on the German party convention of the
CDU was one of the the biggest
attractive platforms was from Iowa so
they are in a charming offensive
nevertheless we have to be very careful
due to the question of digitalization
and cyber security we should not be
black eyed in this context we've
highlighted a number of challenges who
will be the next German Chancellor who
will have to
with those challenges lush it mats or
chiffon your answer one word a German
citizen that was three words the
opportunity to lead lead it will be
somebody from the CDU I think it will
not be somebody from the CSU what are
kids better
[Music]
you